people of the internet welcome back to
another episode of harry potter and the
philosopher's stone
or harry potter and the sorcerer's stone
i feel like every time i say philosopher
stone
people don't get upset but if i say
sorcerer's stone someone in the comments
is always like it's philosopher's stone
so it doesn't really bother me to be
honest but we are back
yet again for another episode and uh if
you missed the last episode we just
finished sneaking past bilch and mrs
norris
and then fred and george brought us down
here we've redeemed 25 beans and got the
rowena ravenclaw wizard card so now
we're gonna head back
up and i'm not really sure what is going
to happen from here i'm i'm
pretty sure we're getting fairly close
to the end of the game i'm not sure if
we're going to beat it today
but in this episode but i do think that
we are getting close to the end at this
point so
we'll just see how far we can make it
today
all right let's see if we're actually
completely past bilge and mrs norris at
this point or if there's going to be
something else that happens with them
okay it looks like we do not have on the
invisibility cloak anymore
so i think we are good to make our way
now i'm tempted
i kind of want to go back here and just
make sure that there aren't any secrets
in this room right here that we could
miss
any wizard cards that could potentially
be hiding
let's see can i allah more of this i
don't think so
okay just making sure i am a
completionist in a lot of games although
i have been playing this without a guide
no guide or anything
so i don't know if i've gotten all the
wizard cards or not
i guess we'll find out at the end i hope
i do let's see how many we have right
now
we're going to the folio magisk so we're
missing one there two
three four five six seven eight
and then the final one right there nine
so we're still missing quite a few
so if we're as close to the end of the
game as i feel like we are
oh stop snape oh man this is it
okay yeah we're definitely not getting
all the wizard cards
hermione ron and harry researched the
secret of the philosopher's stone
stones we're going to go with then
anyone
immortal no wonder someone's trying to
get it
anyone would want it said harry
and he suspected that the package hagrid
had taken from green gods
contained the philosopher's stone
hermione it was the philosophy very
clever
that was down the forbidden corridor
being guarded by
whatever it was that had growled at them
all right so we're doing
this this night's been actually i did
not think it was already time but
he may be planning to steal the floor
closer to him than i thought i guess
there's no way snape would try anything
while dumbledore's around
but dumbledore left 10 minutes ago for
the ministry of matters what
no i just saw him that must mean he was
not he was at the mirror of harrison
i love i love the time in this game it
really does feel like just one
super long day the way that they set it
up
but hey what can you say this this game
is pretty old he's always watching the
forbidden character
we'll just have to take our chances then
oh no here we go is phil's gonna find us
again do we have to do more sneaking
around
it looks like filter somewhere else
tonight
no we don't harry's like uh i may or may
not know where
bilge is hanging out guys
come on let's go okay here we go all
right there's a lot of chests in here
let's go and hit this save
point right here now speaking of the
wizard cards
uh one of the viewers of the stream who
always leaves a comment wario shout out
to wario who let me know
that actually in this game harry potter
and the philosopher's stone for pc
you cannot get any duplicates
so i don't know what made me think that
i was getting duplicate wizard cards
but they confirmed to me that you cannot
get duplicates so there you have it
thanks to uh wario there i think it's
wario land
gold pyramid something like that sorry
wario if i messed up the name
but i appreciate your help and pointing
that out so that was good that we got
those two chocolate frogs there because
you can see our health is still not all
the way up to max now we always like to
check and see which wizard card we got
so it's gonna be this one right here
looks like a quidditch player
roderick plumpton 1889 to 1987. hey
we've got our
first potential wizard who could be
alive in the hogwarts legacy timeline
although 1889 is pretty late
so we keep coming back to that when it
comes to hogwarts legacy guys it really
depends on how
late they're talking when they said late
1800s but
you know it could be 11 years old and
what 1900 so it's probably not gonna be
that late
probably not gonna know this guy he's
gonna be a little baby if it's at the
end of
the late 1800s so he was the seeker for
england's quidditch team
holds british record for fastest capture
of snitch during game
three and a half seconds it's even
faster than we did earlier guys
all right thank you ron appreciate it so
unless we get a whole
lot of wizard cards in this final little
section
uh i think we missed them guys so we'll
have to go back and
try again
all right about to get our first look at
the pc version of fluffy
but we've got to stop snape
that's right sneaky right behind you
hermione we're right behind you
go on take it away leave lead the pack
gary
uh oh oh
there he is fluffy the three-headed dog
that's the thumbnail right there guys
that's gotta be the thumbnail
i don't know maybe not if we get to
voldemort that might be a better
thumbnail we'll see
oh goodness wait what we gotta fight him
wait wait wait okay hold on it's a new
mechanic i just
oh oh the middle one he's going to sleep
see that
oh jeez i did not expect that i thought
he was thought he was happy
[Music]
okay let me get out of the way oh i see
i see i see
[Music]
there you go buddy there you go okay how
about you now
hold on don't fight me don't fight me
[Music]
not close enough dude this is kind of
creepy
oh now the other one woke up
[Music]
whoa wait how do you do this
i'm not going to be able to get this one
in time see look at the other one over
there the far
[Music]
when he's asleep oh when he's asleep you
can actually make it go down even more
okay wait you have got to worry about
that
oh you can hit me over there too no
and this one on the right this is
actually super difficult
oh goodness it's not going well guys
this
is actually insane dude
oh man here we go about to die i'm about
to die
[Music]
wait wait wait wait wait wait
is this it is this it please don't bite
me please don't bite me
go asleep you're all asleep yes
that was way harder than it should have
been i really hope there's some
chocolate frogs down here you have to go
first hermane
no way she said no see you in a minute
all right ron ron's gonna be the brave
one this time i thought we're all
gryffindor's here come on now let's go
okay
it's a soft landing you can jump alright
it should be double snare up next
come on harry come on harry
all right harry let's do this man
[Music]
yep there it is there is
devil snare at least a pc version of
it anyway it's a devil's snare
next time we're going to pay more
attention in apology
[Music]
try not to get too close just relax okay
this is going to be different from the
movie and the book i see
okay so nice that it did give me a
little bit of pill
but oh goodness oh goodness whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa
this was right in my face okay i can't
move forward or backwards so i think all
we can do is go side to side
just kind of like button here spamming
the mouse but oh no this one on the left
over here is getting really close
hermione's getting pretty close to being
set free as he looks like
[Applause]
wait is ron out are they both out
nice all right thanks harry that is not
how you combat devil snare but hey
we'll just we'll just go just go with it
you know they had to make it some sort
of uh
action-packed sequence here at the
finale of the game right
all right here we go gotta catch the
winged keys now
you have to catch the key harry dude i
can't wait to see if they actually put
in the potions challenge or not i feel
like i remember the potions challenge
being in the video game
good luck obviously it's not in the
movie disappointing but
all right where is the key is it gonna
give off something like the snitch to
show me where it is yes it is there's
the rings right there
did i miss it do i need to turn around
or can we just can we just keep going
with this
okay so we made our way all the way back
around there's ron and hermione
okay what what is hitting me the keys
they're attacking
all right i'm gonna turn around because
it does not look like i'm getting any
closer that way
oh there it is there it is dude there it
is
oh no no no don't do that
back here come back here
i wonder what this is like with a
controller it's got to be easier than it
left mouse or with the uh not left mouse
stuff
the keyboard man my left hand
having to use everything on my left hand
to control this right now
my pinky my index finger my middle
finger all of them guys
everything except my thumb oh
stop stop come on harry come on you got
this dude
you're right there on it get through the
ring
[Music]
where are you going where are you going
going that way
okay
no
almost almost almost
yes yes let's go
got the key all right open that door
harry
because your health is dangerously low
dangerously low
[Music]
all right up next it should be wizard's
chess
come on harry come on harry
all right wizards chess indeed
the next puzzle is a gigantic chessboard
ron's gone through to play
i hope oh wait what are we not gonna
play with him do we not get to play with
chess
okay let's head on up
i'm still trying to hit shift like i'm
on the broom to go faster
all right stay point nice and that's the
end no i'm kidding i'm kidding
could you imagine if i just stopped it
right are you all right
i just in the stream right here but i've
been hurt
it's up to you now oh we don't get to
play wizards
come on harry you have to be careful and
avoid the pieces
they all move one square at a time i
guess they wanted to make this friendly
to kids
safely they're like we're gonna actually
have rules of chess and ron's already
played
so okay wait what am i supposed to do
now
move marker with arrow keys
move marker wait what marker can can you
tell me again hermione look onto the
board harry to start oh walk on the
board to start the game okay
oh no
that one protecting me or something
no goodness they're heading my way
wait what what's going on what's going
on
what do i do i have
no idea what i'm supposed to do guys
is this guy about to kill me i said i
need to make them fight
or something like they're getting closer
shouldn't they fight now
okay they're fighting yeah yeah
[Music]
okay so
all right um maybe right here
no
[Music]
oh no oh no no
no now the black piece attacks
this is like such weird rules it would
have been way
easier if they just had an actual chest
oh no this is not good they're all
closing in on me
this was the wrong move you guys
this was absolutely the wrong move
yep dead
why is this harder than actual chest you
guys
why
like i don't feel like i can even get
close to them because
they immediately okay let me try this
i'm gonna try to get them to to go into
each other yes
okay so he wanted to take that same
piece okay and then that destroys them
okay now the bad part about it is this
time i did not get those two guys
to go into each other but that's okay
you know why that's okay because
i'm gonna go
could i go back then he's gonna move
closer isn't he
what if i go i think if i go
here yeah then he's gonna try to take
his space
okay there we go there we go
all right now you're you're coming on
over okay okay and now
i'm gonna go here and then the other guy
yes there we go see
i knew we'd get it eventually guys i
knew we'd get it eventually
all right hey they just leave ron behind
they're just like hey he'll be okay
well ron will make it we're we're not
gonna worry about ron he's
he's all good all right another save
point coming up that's nice
i am a little bit worried about our
health here
maybe one of these potions is a health
potion what do you think
oh no the exit is blocked by i am
excited to see that they actually put
this task in there choose the right
potion
i was really disappointed that they
didn't have this in the movie
all right so do we actually look like it
will help us through the fire oh
come on wait then choose wisely
okay okay i got it got it still got it
all right yep yep okay
we're good i know it's gonna be this one
right here right here here it goes again
what no
this is not what i had in mind for this
one but i have to commend them for at
least
okay still got it how about you chat you
got it
got it chat you got it
is this one right here in the middle i'm
just kidding
i'm just kidding
one more time are you serious are you
serious right now
whoa yeah i could do without the
commentary hermione i could do without
that
all right all right all right i still
got it i still got it how about you how
about you guys in the comments
there we go please that's gotta be it
right
r you kidding me right now hermione
that's ridiculous
still got it still got it
oh whoa whoa whoa
honestly the camera right there at the
end threw me off more than anything
you picked the right one oh i was
worried because it wasn't bubbling at
first
hermione's just sitting over there whole
time like i know which one it is harry
i know which one you've got to find on
your own i'll go back and help ron
good luck harry oh now now we're
concerned with rod
oh goodness all right guys here we go
the conclusion to harry potter and the
philosopher's stone
he makes his way i
just almost missed this and you know
it's gonna be a wizard card
you know it's gonna be a wizard card if
beans pop out of that okay fine
fine not beans something i needed not a
wizard card
but something i needed
it wasn't snake it was quirrell
man what an what an incredible moment in
the books guys
like reading that as a i think i was in
i was in seventh grade
and as someone who hadn't read a whole
lot of books
like that you know i'd read plenty of
books but not a lot of fantasy books
i was just absolutely floored i'm sure
older readers saw it coming but i just
i was so sold on snape man i was so
incredibly sold on it
the man with two faces turning that page
and seeing uh i'm
pretty sure the last words that the
chapter before it
he says but it wasn't snape it wasn't
even
voldemort then you turn the page it was
coral
it's like what i cannot believe this
all right so we're not going to be able
to get to him quite yet okay he just
all right he sealed that door shut he
knows we're here i'm meeting you here
potter
is not expecting someone else well it's
me scared
stuttering professor quirrell you're far
too inquisitive to remain among the
living
jesus oh my goodness he just a kid
could you imagine oh
wow they should have picked a color
besides green though right
okay i was gonna try and get the
chocolate frogs but i think he's just
gonna start
shooting at me he did start shooting at
me
okay so we need to use them for cover
oh now he's now he switches it up guys
all right let's do this right here can i
just
i'm pretty sure do we have to get all of
these across
oh that's not even right quarrel
that's why it was a different color wait
can i not can i not shoot it forward
again
no no
why can i not shoot that one forward is
it stuck or something
okay hold on maybe i just need to back
up a little bit what is going on
like once he hits it that's it
[Music]
i need to move that one over no don't
hop on there
don't hop on there harry
okay that one's still allowed me to move
now what i need to do is quickly
yeah shoot it over that way all right
he's focused on that one now maybe i can
i have no idea what's going on with this
one
what all right fine fine quarrel
i'll move another one then
okay good we got that one blocked off
i'm gonna go ahead and grab another
chocolate frog here
no i really don't want to hop on that
i'm just trying to
on harry come on harry you can do this
yes lock it into position right there
still going for the ak on me
no no no no no no no get down
get down and turn around here we go
good all right that one's in a good spot
now i just need to send this one all the
way down i don't know if is he done with
the red curse trying to send them back
oh no he wasn't he just tried one right
there
[Music]
all right i think what i'm gonna do yeah
actually send it back a little bit
there we go we got it locked in now
locked in and we're gonna jump right up
into your
face quirrell we are not afraid
and now we confront you take that
you will not succeed again
he just walks away from
he just walks away that's it all right
and at this point the game is like we
are giving you plenty of chocolate frogs
we want you to absolutely be max health
so that's what i'm gonna do i'm gonna
get some max health
then i'm gonna hit that save point leave
those two frogs i don't know why i mean
i'm already at full just in case
something crazy happens
all right here we go there's the mirror
let's go ahead and get the stone out
harry
yep yep there it is
this whole first book is about
wow except not really
i mean it's give me the stones it's kind
of about the stone but
it's a very small part oh here we go
dude pc version of voldemort the reveal
it's gonna look like guys what's it
gonna look like
oh that is creepy
oh my gosh i think coral is actually a
little bit creepier than voldemort was
right there
oh dude this is the stuff of nightmares
what he's got like flamethrowers coming
out of his hands
no
oh my goodness we just crashed a pillar
on top of voldemort
or quirrell mort okay wait we need to
get him to shoot that
there we go get it rocking now
blast it right on him
oh goodness no no no no no no no
yeah shoot that shoot that right there
shoot that quarrel mort
yeah oh guys we're not hitting him
though
this is bad we are not connecting on
these
maybe i need to get him a little bit
closer okay yeah right there
now shoot it there we go
how is that not hitting him because his
life's not going down guys
it's gonna happen if i run out of these
[Music]
oh we're about to find out
i must have just connected perfectly
with the first one
[Music]
wait can i just do a regular flipindo on
him
you flipping voldemort
oh man this is not good guys this is not
good
what is that what's that purple stuff
[Music]
no dude that does a lot of damage too
i think i'm beat like i don't think
there's any way to recover from this
wait his health is lower than it was the
last time
can i actually hit him with a fluffindo
[Music]
no chasing me
[Music]
and harry potter is dead
okay let's try this again
okay so the first one we just get i mean
it's like perfect perfect connection
like how do i get him to get yes a
little bit closer
how about that oh there we go dude
we just got to get you in a little bit
closer quarrel more
come on buddy come on oh goodness no
not that yeah yeah yeah right there
right there oh
direct hit again all right come on
come on
fire it oh we missed him that time
it's not good
yeah come on you gotta get closer
there you go
how does that not hit him he's like
right there dude
do i really have to do this whole thing
again
come on you got to get closer than that
[Music]
i don't think it gets close enough well
walk a little bit this way yeah yeah
right there dude
right there that doesn't hit i was about
to say like he is right behind that but
now what
like now what guys
he's serious
like i have nothing
wait did digital actually do something
that time
what a terrible boss fight if there's
nothing else i could do
oh wait wait wait could i like deflect
that back
[Music]
that one that was moving really slow
let's watch this
are you serious he's dead again
oh come on get a little bit closer
all right he's around half
oh wait you can shoot the mirror
oh yes there we go direct hit
i have to shoot the mirror
[Music]
okay that's just not even fair no
move harry move
i'm dead i'm dead dude
okay that got him that was a direct hit
on him
i just have to keep the mirror between
us
just have to keep the mirror between us
what are you talking about
okay that one for whatever reason that
one's like a super powerful ak it passes
through
oh we got you dude we got you are you
kidding me one more time
i can't do this i can't do this
no here comes the slow one here comes
the slow one
oh i think we made it
oh yes
yes finally you guys finally
wow talk about an epic death
oh goodness
and dumbledore just strolls it
like literally as squirrel is falling
over here comes dumbledore
strolling against between yourself and
professor there's a complete sequence oh
goodness so naturally the whole school
knows
all right let's the stones taking the
end credits together here
harry remained fearful that its loss
would not prevent lord voldemort's
return
dumbledore right you are harry right you
are
[Music]
nevertheless harry if our battles do no
more than
slow voldemort's return with luck he may
never regain his power at all
hmm
harry made his way down to the end of
the year feast alone that night
the great hall was decked out in green
and silver
to celebrate slytherin winning the house
[Music]
cup oh by the way
oh by the way he took a seat between ron
and hermione
trying to ignore the stairs of the other
states dumbledore you got any more
points
got any of those points you can hand out
cup announced
[Music]
storm of cheering and stamping broke out
from the slytherin table
yes yes well done however well continue
dumbledore
in recognition of mr harry potter's pure
nerve and outstanding courage
i award gryffindor
okay okay it's getting it erupted with
cheers and applause
the additional points had won the house
cup for oh that's not exactly
what happened but okay i appreciate you
know they're trying to keep it nice and
succinct here at the end better than
winning at quidditch or christmas
or knocking out mountain trolls he would
never
ever forget tonight
the end the end
oh wait what the epilogue
a post-credits scene
wait what what is happening
this is what they've been working on the
whole time
hey there's a chest in there how do i
get in there
what is going on
oh my goodness there you go
guys the mystery has been solved
that is why fred and george have been
collecting beans
the entire school year in what really
just felt like a day of school
at hogwarts to unlock this secret
uh collect 24 wizard cards and 250
party bots beans then defeat you must
not be named okay yes so
we missed out it looks like on quite a
few wizard cards let's go back
uh one on that page there that makes two
there
three four five six seven
wow i mean and i thought i was really
trying to explore
a lot of the areas but we missed out on
seven wizard cards plus
you know when you count the final one
there that would be eight that we missed
out on
and there we go guys harry potter and
the philosopher's stone credits roll
the first one is in the books thank you
guys so much for watching be sure you
come back for our next game
in our let's play series most likely
going to be doing harry potter in the
chamber of secrets if you haven't
already voted i
did put up a poll here on youtube for
which game you'd like to see me play
next
regardless of what wins in that poll
though i will definitely be putting up
harry potter and the chamber of secrets
at some point so if you're watching this
years from now then it's
very likely already on youtube so go
ahead and check that out i'll make sure
put a link to it in the top right corner
when it is out so you would see it on
the screen now
but as always guys thank you so much for
watching i'll talk to you again soon